in kalifornien für bild ist jens lenski
es dann die derzeitige situation gerade
also ich befinde mich hier momentan im
norden von los angeles und wie sie
anhand meines gesichtes erkennen können
wir nicht schon sehr schwitzen das ist
neun uhr morgens ortszeit und schon hier
sind die mitte 30 grad temperaturen wie
ist die situation ja die hitzewelle der
letzten tage beziehungsweise wochen ja
sehr extrem ist wir sind hier konstant
insbesondere den tälern in los angeles
bei den mitte 40 grad was eher untypisch
ist für diese jahreszeit und zurzeit
hüten hier sieben waldbrände im großraum
los angeles davon fallen zwei unter die
kategorie groß eines ist hier im norden
in santa clarita sie sehen dass sie im
hintergrund die ganzen rausch warten
eigentlich kann man hier nicht weit
sehen das san fernando valley wo sich
hinten am ende auch die filmstudios
befinden die kann man auch nicht sehen
aufgrund der dichten rauchschwaden
wie gesagt haben zwei große vorjahr wir
haben vier kleine bis mittlere
waldbrände sind nicht untypisch für die
region aber zum einen der zeitpunkt ist
er ist eigentlich so der beginn der
waldbrandsaison der saison dann die
anzahl ist sehr untypisch dass man so
viele brände gleichzeitig hat was auch
die koordination und einsatzbereitschaft
unheimlich kompliziert und die hitze
also die hitze ist der hauptfaktor
zumindest hier in südkalifornien in
nord-kalifornien warnes unwetter bzw
blitzeinschläge die zu dem feuer geführt
haben
und ich kann ihnen noch ein paar zahlen
nennen in den letzten tagen wurden in
kalifornien 370 waldbrände gemeldet dass
eine wahnsinn zahl ist sind momentan
60.000 haushalte evakuiert und weitere
100.000 oncol und allein in den letzten
48 stunden hat die feuerwehr über 11.000
blitzeinschläge in kalifornien
registriert und dementsprechend ist also
die lage sehr kritisch aber das sind ja
zahlen mit denen man überhaupt nicht
rechnet
wenn du sagst 60.000 menschen die
irgendwie ihr haus verlassen mussten
kommt die feuerwehr überhaupt noch
dagegen an haben die überhaupt noch eine
chance die waldbrände irgendwie unter
kontrolle zu bringen
ich hab leider etwas schlechte
verbindungen hier aber ich denke die
frage verstanden noch kommt die
feuerwehr den bränden nach weil der
verheerendste faktor heißt ja noch nicht
eingetreten und zwar sind das die
wüstenwinde die sogenannten seiner ender
santa ana bands ihr eigentlich erst im
oktober oder november kommen also die
lage zumindest für los angeles und auch
in nordkalifornien vor san francisco ist
nicht unmittelbar bedrohlich für die
städte jedoch ist die situation sehr
beängstigend weil dies natürlich auch
schon extremer trend ist für die
nächsten zwei monate die kommen und dort
fängt eigentlich erst die eigentliche
vorher saison an ein indikator ist auch
der hitzerekord den wir vor drei vier
tagen im death valley hatten
dort wurde die zweithöchste jemals auf
diesem planeten gemessene temperatur mit
56 grad celsius gemessen und anhand
dieser indizien kann man schon sagen
dass dieses jahr ein sehr heißer und
volker sommer in kalifornien wird